wir können nicht diejenigen die sich
nicht an regeln halten zum maßstab dafür
machen wie wir insgesamt gegen diese
pandemie vorgehen ich glaube dass wir im
augenblick auf einem guten weg sind wir
haben selbst kritisiert wie das impf und
das testmanagement angelaufen ist
insofern wäre mir selbst lieber gewesen
wir wären mit dem fortschritt weiter
man muss sich das einmal vorstellen das
ist ja wahnsinn also es gibt schon
mehrere millionen dämpfte die haben wir
diesen gelben pass wie die das dann
sozusagen technisch anwenden können das
völlig offen und völlig unten unklar ist
auch wie das ganze dann in einem
digitalen impfpass münden soll
im land ruhe zu lange auf faxgeräte
gesetzt statt auch eine digitalisierung
voranzubringen habe ich will gar nicht
hier einfach schuldzuweisung verteilen
mein gott da verteilt sich die verteilt
sie die verantwortung glaube ich
ziemlich breit aber wir reden ja darüber
gerade was keine perspektive sein und in
der tat wollen wir nicht dass wir in den
nächsten block down durch zu schnelles
öffnen rein ja ich bin auch der meinung
wir müssen grundrechte menschen
zurückgeben das ist nichts was man
vorenthalten kann ja und dann glaube ich
dass wir jetzt mit hochdruck weiter
impfen müssen
da ist zum glück zum glück hat sich die
geschwindigkeit erhöht so dass wenn wir
noch eine weile durchhalten so dass
allen menschen im angebot haben können
und dass das eine gute möglichkeit dann
ist auch weiter zu öffnen sodass der
länder auch machen
ich stelle hilft haben als wir wer
geimpft ist soll seine freiheit wieder
bekommen das ist eine eine das sollte
uns stolz machen dass da wieder leben
möglich ist das sollte kein anlass für
neid sein fragt herr blume restaurants
ja warum ich das sagen restaurants auch
für geimpfte dass nämlich das gut sagen
ist kann kein anders möchte ich als wenn
jemand der jetzt geimpft ist das ja ich
beantworte es ja es kann keinen anspruch
geben von jemand der geimpft ist das
jetzt das öffentliche heimat sozusagen
wieder aufmacht aber ich bin mir sicher
dass wir wenn wir über öffnung der
außengastronomie vielleicht im ersten
schritt reden oder öffnung ohne waren
von kultureinrichtungen das
selbstverständlich diejenigen die
geimpft sind das dann auch konzept
konzepte denkbar sind wovon denen diese
einrichtungen nutzen ab nächster woche
biergarten außen in bayern mit
es ist leider noch saukalt in bayern ich
sehe das mit dem biergarten noch nicht
aber herr uns wenn wir sie dann mit
ihren etwas nach bayern 1 und dann sehen
wir uns im biergarten